I think I'm on my schedule for July he's
like the glitter of our show he'll
always be lingering like this confetti
here
days and days later but how are you
feeling you finally wrapped your final
show Ryan I didn't know what it was
going to feel like I thought well you
know you can handle this and then they
roll the clips and pop balloons
but the sad music and the editing of
those pieces together it makes you
realize how many Great Moments we have
had I should remember any of those
moments no but I was convinced it was us
no I know it was us because we were
watching it thank God but we were
staring at each other I kept saying
well she was holding me up a couple
times because I really like it I get
very much
[Music]
it's been hard because we've been
preparing ourselves for this for a long
time I've never been through anything
like this neither am I yeah I mean this
is really like it's a unique sensation
for all of us because we are like
it's really like a you're our family
member in the best way you know like in
a very very close way and so we Champion
Ryan no matter what he does it's so
evident you guys have had this
incredibly close relationship over the
past six years that we've we've been
able to see on television it was there
years prior what did you say to one
another before you walked out on stage
for the final time as co-host she said
to me I think I'm going to lose it when
you return this I actually I said to him
I think I'm gonna lose it but I actually
turned to him and I said I'm gonna punch
you no I said I looked at him and I said
this really sucks it was like oh this is
our last like walkout for a while anyway
Monday morning we're gonna have Mark
Consuelos join it'll be very celebratory
I know yeah I mean that's the thing is
like to go from Ryan to mark is almost
like same same yeah same same mug change
kind of yeah what advice did you give to
Mark Mark doesn't need advice he's been
he's he's spent believe this or not more
hours with Kelly than I have he's the
only man on the planet that's done that
um he's gonna be great and I'm so
excited for both HR is not going to know
what to make you know because you know I
don't know if you heard around here
you know uh offset uh frolicking is
frowned upon so
we're gonna have to really be on our
mind our p's and q's while we're on the
air I
am a crafter or it's maybe it's popped
out let's talk about how you got it oh
yes okay don't touch the spot you have
just blossomed as Kelly said over the
course of the six years we've seen your
dancing skills get better your acting
skills is the right word I mean it's
it's pretty impressive the one thing I
have to say that I am so like I'm so
happy about because I've always known
and we've known here like who Ryan is
like at his core but all of his jobs are
about featuring other people
and I'm so glad that we got to feature
Ryan because he is one of I always say
one in a zillion he is like the most
special person talented kind
conscientiously
she knows the magic power she has oh my
gosh look at him I'm just I'm very
because I like for him but I like for
him to see himself the way we see him
I'm gonna watch that show what do you
got up your sleeve next secret only fan
oh
Kelly just broke the news didn't she you
beat me to it Carl can we get one final
Seacrest out from you
Seacrest out
[Music]